-[ Gasps ]
-What?!
It did it, babe!
-Ooh!
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-♪ We in the house ♪
-Come on!
-Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests...
Musical guest...
And the legendary Roots crew.
It's "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
-♪ We in the house, y'all ♪
-And now, here's Jimmy.
-Hi, everybody, and welcome to
"The Tonight Show: At Home
Edition."
My name's Jimmy Fallon.
Thank you so much
for watching our show tonight.
Let's get to some jokes.
Well, guys, everybody is
talking about this.
This is insane.
Last night, President Trump
claimed that
he's been taking
hydroxychloroquine
to prevent himself from getting
the coronavirus.
When told the drug is for
treating malaria, Trump said,
"If it's good enough for
the First Lady,
it's good enough for me."
That's right -- Trump shocked
everyone by saying
that he's taking the drug, even
though it has not been proven
to help treat COVID-19.
Right after he said it,
Dr. Fauci immediately
put on a mask so no one
could see him laughing.
[ Laughs ]
That's a little Muttley.
Yeah, after Trump
made the announcement,
a lot of experts told him what
he was doing is dangerous.
Trump was like, "Relax.
if anything goes wrong,
I can just drink bleach
and clean it all out.
I'm good."
[ As Trump ] If you swallow a
U.V. light bulb, good as new.
[ Normal voice ]
This is going viral.
An Israeli company
has created a mask
that opens for you
to eat through.
Oh, that's been a problem people
have been having.
So, I guess when
you squeeze this thing,
it opens and closes
a mechanical mouth.
Take a look at this.
Yeah. It costs $19.99,
plus your dignity.
It's actually made by
the same person
who invented
Steven Tyler's mouth.
Listen to this.
I saw that Michael Jordan
is selling his Chicago mansion
for almost $15 million.
It's a great place to live if
you've always dreamed of
disappointing the hell
out of trick-or-treaters.
Hmm.
I heard about a priest in
Detroit who used a squirt gun
to shoot holy water onto his
churchgoers while they drove by.
And after that,
he shot wafers into their mouths
from a T-shirt cannon.
This is crazy.
Scientists in Antarctica
say that they've found evidence
of a parallel universe where
time actually runs backwards.
Then they were like, "Oh, wait.
We were just holding
the research the wrong way.
Sorry."
And, finally,
I saw that researchers
are working on
a coronavirus test
where you sneeze onto
your phone.
Sounds gross,
but I'd rather watch that
than someone eat that through
that mechanical mask.
That is our monologue,
everybody.
We have a great show tonight.
Oh, my goodness.
Ben Stiller is on the show.
I love Ben Stiller.
I've known him for a while.
You know, that was
my big "SNL" --
That was kind of my
big breakout show,
was the Ben Stiller show.
-Right.
-Because of Ben.
-He's done that
for a lot of people.
-He said -- Yeah.
He said -- He goes, "Have you
heard this new kid, Sandler?"
And everyone was like,
"Yeah, we know.
He auditioned.
I mean, we hired him
for the show.
We know who he is."
He's like, "You should have
him do Sandler."
They're like, "Yeah, we'll see.
He's brand-new."
This was only like my third show
or something like that.
And he's like -- So, that night,
I did Sandler in
"Celebrity Jeopardy!"
and I also did "Weekend Update."
I did impressions with
Colin Quinn.
And that was -- And then I got
all sorts of phone calls
and fun stuff.
It was super-fun.
I'll never forget that.
That was awesome.
Thank you, Ben Stiller.
We're going to talk about his
show, "Escape Room,"
that's airing
this Thursday on NBC
for Red Nose Day with him
and Jack Black
and Lisa Kudrow
and Courteney Cox.
It's like a mini
"Friends" reunion.
It's gonna be -- It's hilarious.
And, also, we're going to
talk about his dad,
who sadly passed away,
Jerry Stiller,
who, gosh, was so funny.
I mean, but we're gonna talk to
Ben later in the show.
Then Hannah Gadsby,
speaking of funny.
We'll talk about her
new special, "Douglas",
that premieres May 26th
on Netflix.
And then we're gonna
close out the show
with one of our
favorite musical guests.
Tim McGraw will be here tonight.
And it's super-fun.
Oh, quickly,
I want to thank everyone
for voting for us for
the Webby Awards.
We won two Webbys.
So thank you very much
for voting.
One was for writing for
the Amazon Alexa thing
that we did for
"Tell Me a Joke."
And then the other is for
Best Celebrity or Fan
Social Media Content.
That's maj. For the Webbys?
-That's amazing.
-That's the one you want to win.
Thank you, guys, for voting.
I love it, love it, love it.
It's awesome.
Hey, speaking of
fun things to do
with the web and the Internet,
what a segue this is.
Over the weekend, I talked to
my pal Steve Higgins,
my good friend, and he
showed me some Zoom hacks
that are really helpful.
Check it out.
-Hey, Higgins. How's it going?
-Great. How about you?
-You know, hanging in there.
What have you been up to?
-Well, everybody's working
from home these days,
so I came up with some great
work-from-home hacks.
First, I figured out some new
ways you can slack off
in a virtual meeting
by using Zoom backgrounds.
-You can use Zoom backgrounds
to slack off?
How does that work?
-Like this. See?
That was a Zoom-video background
I made of myself, Jimmy.
-You were a Zoom background
the whole time?
I had no idea.
-Look at him.
He has no clue
what we're talking about,
but it seems like he does.
I can just plop this
into a work Zoom
and then I can spend my
time doing important things,
like bonding with my kids
by screaming at them to
reorganize my Blu-rays.
-Show me another one.
-This next hack requires
the help of a friend.
And that friend is yourself.
Hey, your car's on fire outside.
Jimmy, his car [laughs]
isn't on fire.
In fact, he doesn't even
have one.
That's a Zoom video.
And that's just a normal excuse
to get him out of
a cyber meeting.
-You were a Zoom background
that whole time? Wow.
-Wow.
I've never seen
two of me before.
I feel like I'm in one of
those beer commercials.
"And twins."
More like "And me's."
-What else you got?
Okay, for this next one...
Package!
Oh, shoot.
I guess the delivery man's here.
Can you hang on a second, Jimmy?
Yeah, delivery for...me?
Hey, "me"? That's my name.
Yeah, but which one of us
is the real Higgins, Jimmy?
Trick question.
They're both Zoom backgrounds.
I'm the real Higgins.
Jimmy, you don't -- you don't
seem impressed this time.
That's because Jimmy was a
Zoom background the whole time.
[ Gasps ]
Oh, my.
Wow! Six Steve Higginses.
You know what that means.
We could start our own Avengers
made up of six dads
with no superpowers,
and one of them is deathly
allergic to peanuts.
-Six Steve Higginses, everybody.
We'll be right back.